[Musique]
c'est vraiment prêt à travailler avec le
magicien ya un truc qui me fascine chez
les dj producteur c'est que c'est un peu
les grands manitous c'est pour ça que
j'adore ce personnage de ce nom parce
que j'ai vu avec dj dj kore en
l'occurrence mais j'imagine que c'est
comme ça avec d'autres j'ai vu à quel
point il sent que les choses avant même
l'artiste avant même le rappeur c'est à
dire que ils te font venir en studio ils
ont déjà trouvé le morceau qui va te
correspondent
parfois ils ont même trouvé la mélodie
pour le rappeur en tout cas je l' ai
vécu ça sur les bo de mes films ok vas-y
des mois ce qui te manque ce que tu peux
me rajouter le bit stop là dessus plutôt
rapide suppose
bref et le moins agressif comme ça et
puis c'est assez étonnant de voir ces
mecs qui vieillissent mais qui continue
à être dans l'air du temps qui continue
à produire
tu vois par exemple un mec comme comme
dj comme d'autres beatmaker il ya des
générations entières de rappeurs qui
leur passe dans les mains
depuis qu'ils s'éteignent puis lui sont
toujours là et ils ont des idées des
facultés et des capacités à se
renouveler
artistiquement et c'est assez étonnant
docker je kiffe jouer ce personnage
parce que j'ai beaucoup de respect pour
pour ces mecs là quoi le travail
commence avec tout le monde ce n'est pas
du tout
ça passe au problème dans l'ambiguïté du
personnage de snow hill vient de
l'ambiguïté que j'ai pu aussi sentir
avec des beatmakers que j'ai fréquenté
qui sont des mecs qui doivent être
opportuniste c'est normal edouard sentir
qu'avec quel mec les inspire en quel mec
filles d'ailleurs il croit et parfois
oui ça va provoquer des problèmes parce
que ils ont un gros beat ou un gros hit
acquis qu'ils vont préférer donner un
autre mec et voilà je viens donner mon
son c'est pourquoi je ferais ça lui a
donné mon frère me prendre pour un con
une création originale à découvrir en
avant-première en ce moment sur my canal